I'm not going to spend a ton of time on this but
because I told you about it earlier this week I
do want to follow up earlier this week after
being arrested for a second time Donald Trump
went to the Cuban restaurant in Miami Versailles
and at that restaurant Donald Trump promised food
for everyone okay remember this bizarre moment
are you ready are you ready food for everyone
okay my immediate reaction was I'd get
a credit card up front before giving
anybody food that supposedly Trump is
going to pay for the Miami New Times
can now report that Donald Trump did not
pay for anybody's food at Versailles the
article confirms Trump opted to decompress
with a trip to Versailles in Little Havana
Trump and his Entourage arrived there
shortly after leaving the courthouse
Trump said food for everyone so the new times
wondered did Trump treat his fan club to some food
it turns out no one got anything not even a
cafecito to go a knowledgeable Source assures the
new times that Trump's stop was 10 minutes long it
didn't leave time for anyone to eat anything much
less place an order and of course Donald Trump did
not leave any instructions to Bill him or charge
his credit card or whatever the case may be this
is a very small story in the broader context of
everything that happened in the last week which
was an absolutely insane week it is not the most
important story but it is a reminder that this
is a habitually dishonest and Despicable guy who
cares about his supporters only as far as they
are useful to him and the Versailles incident is
the epitome of that he shows up they're cheering
they sing him happy birthday they're praying over
him the photo op is extraordinarily useful and
so he yells out food for everyone but then he
leaves because he doesn't actually care about it
he doesn't actually want to give anyone anything
he doesn't actually respect or value these
people anywhere beyond the extent to which
they are useful to his campaign we saw it with
the fundraising grifts we saw it around elections
we've seen it so many times food for everyone I
would have gotten the credit card up front he paid
for nobody's food we have a fantastic program
for you today few programming notes number one
we will be off on Monday for Juneteenth number
two then I will be here Tuesday but then away
for a wedding not my wedding I will be on the west
coast for a wedding so after the Tuesday show for
which I will be here then we'll have some great
guest hosts I think you will enjoy it make sure
that you are subscribed to the YouTube channel we
made more progress in this last week towards the
2 million uh subscriber goal than we have in many
many months let's close out the week super strong
at youtube.com the davidpackman show it's free at
costs nothing and also we are starting to put a
Republican primary debates on the streaming
calendar I know that it is insane because
it is only June we're getting to the end of June
into July of 2023 but the Republican debates are
starting the first one is scheduled for August
23. uh it will be a Fox News debate we are
figuring out whether we can stream it live without
getting absolutely crushed by Fox news's copyright
enforcement division I will have news about that
soon but we will do everything we can to bring you
as much of campaign 2024 as we can let's take a
very quick break we've got a packed program ahead
of the three-day weekend one of our sponsors
today is fume not everything in a bad habit is
wrong so instead of a drastic uncomfortable change
why not just remove the bad part from your habit
fume is an Innovative award-winning device that
does exactly that fume is not electronic there's
no Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just a
delicious flavored air that makes replacing
your bad habit easy your fume comes with an
adjustable airflow dial and is designed with
movable Parts which is great for fidgeting which
can be great for people breaking bad habits look
at what people online are saying they weren't
sure what to expect but ended up loving the
taste and the feel stopping is something lots
of people put off because it's difficult to do
but switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the next
fumes success story head on over to try fumed dot
com and use the code Pacman to save ten percent
when you get the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is down below